- I was just told we have footage.
We have video of Donnie Wahlberg
and his brother Mark
serenading the family dog
when they were little.
So I want to see this.
Let's see this.
(Rick Astley's "Never Gonna Give You Up")
♪ Never gonna give you up ♪
♪ Never gonna let you down ♪
♪ Never gonna run around and desert you ♪
(cheering)
That's right!
That's right, y'all!
Please welcome the man who's
rolled his way into our lives
when we least expected it,
and he's also part of the
Mixtape Tour 2022, Rick Astley!
(smooth jazz intro plays)
(crowd cheering)
Oh my gosh, welcome to the show, Rick.
Is it true?
Your look in that video was a total fluke?
- Yeah. It's a total mess
is what it is, to be honest.
I mean, it wasn't styled in any way.
All those clothes are my own clothes.
I mean, look at the
raincoat, come on, man.
It's the middle of July when
we filmed that video, I think.
It makes me sweat actually,
looking at that video,
it actually makes me sweat.
It brings back great memories
and it brings back
terrifying memories as well.
- I thought it was iconic.
Everyone knows it and loves it.
But here is a guy who took
Rickrolling to another level.
Watch this.
This is amazing.
That's a QR code. And
when you scan it, well.
("Never Gonna Give You Up" plays)
(laughter)
- What a way to be a part
of pop culture forever.
So, do you have a favorite Rickroll?
- Favorite Rickroll?
I mean, so many people have
done so many crazy things
with that thing.
My ultimate ultimate favorite I think is,
I was told that the White
House was Rickrolled,
everybody on staff and Obama
was the president at the time,
so even he got Rickrolled
that day in an email
that everybody got, so I kinda
thought that was amazing,
but I mean, there's just been
some crazy ones over the time,
to be honest.
It's the song that keeps giving
that's the way I look at it.
(clapping)
- Oh yeah, you write that great
of a song it's gonna happen.
Did you see Ted-- Do you watch Ted Lasso?
- Of course. I'm a massive fan, huge fan.
- Oh my gosh. I love it.
And they use your song
there too, that's amazing.
I just didn't know if
you saw that episode.
- No, it's just unbelievable.
And Hannah Waddingham,
who sang the tune as well,
she's a great, great singer
and it kinda brought a tear
to my eye to be honest,
because like I say,
a lot of people have done
some fun things with that,
they've even tattooed themselves,
but I think to see somebody do
it so emotionally that song,
you know what I mean, and
kinda turn it on its head.
It's just incredible. So yeah.
- Oh man, Hannah was just on the show
and I'm a fan for life.
I loved her from Ted Lasso,
but in person she's even just
more of a joy. I love her.